6 Minute English from BBCLearningEnglish.com
Hello, this is 6 Minute English from BBCLearningEnglish. I'm Neil.
And I'm Beth.
If your deaf or hard of hearing, watching television would be impossible without subtitles.
The words of dialogue added at the bottom of the screen,
explaining what the characters are saying.
Subtitled captions aren't only for dialogue.
In the most dramatic action-packed scenes of a movie, there might be no one speaking,
but there are plenty of sounds. A scream, a thrilling car chase,
and all these sounds need to be described as well.
In this programme we'll be meeting Carly Vitovska, a subtitle who works on the
stranger things show to find out more. And of course, we'll be learning some useful new vocabulary as well.
But first, I have a question for you, Neil.
Movie subtitles are written ahead of time, but subtitling for live TV has to be done in the moment.
As the person is speaking, this can lead to mistakes, sometimes very funny ones,
including a subtitle which appeared in an interview for the BBC 6 o'clock news in 2019.
But what did the subtitle say? Was it A, we can't allow Spider-Man to become Prime Minister,
B, we can't allow Superman to become Prime Minister,
or C, we can't allow Batman to become Prime Minister.
Hmm, I guess the subtitling mistake involved Spider-Man?
I'll reveal the answer later in the programme.
Of course, it's not just deaf audiences that subtitles help.
The translated subtitles of foreign films are great for learning languages,
letting you read a word and hear how it's pronounced at the same time.
And because subtitles describe everything from monster squelches to bombs exploding,
it's a great way to learn new adjectives.
Here's subtitler, Carli Vittowska, explaining to BBC Radio 4 programme Word of Mouse,
how her choice of adjective creates emotion for the viewer.
It depends on the genre and depends on the shows.
And so if you have a very upbeat sort of period piece where the music is very
jauntay, like you would use the word jauntay to describe the music,
it's just, it's creating an idea of what a sound is like and using a very, very descriptive
word in order to do so.
Carli bases her descriptions on the film's genre, a style of film, music or book with its own
particular set of features. The sound effects needed for a thriller like Stranger Things,
Creeking Stairs and Sudden Screams are very different from the sounds used in historical
period dramas, which are more upbeat, light-hearted and cheerful.
This influences the adjective Carli chooses to describe a sound.
For example, upbeat music might be described as jauntay, full of energy and confidence.
Subtitles started out as an accessibility feature for deaf audiences and to translate foreign
language films into English. But since the growth of online streaming services like Netflix,
subtitling has become something of an art.
Carli belongs to a team of subtitlers who try to make their descriptions as close as possible
to the sounds they hear. Here she tells BBC Radio 4's Word of Mouth about a time her team found
exactly the right word.
I loved gobsmacked silence because you were able to tell that people were like almost on the
verge of a gasp or on the verge of like a shock and that was the atmosphere. But there wasn't actually
a sound. So when my colleague came up with that one, I definitely wanted to give him a virtual high five.
In this scene, the surprise characters were about to gasp, taking a short quick breath of air.
There was no speech or sound in the scene, but Carli's team found the perfect adjective to
describe the silence. Gobsmacked, which is slang for being so surprised you can't speak.
This was definitely one description that deserved a high five, lifting up your hand to clap hands
with someone else as a greeting or to say well done. In fact, the phrase gobsmacked silence was so good
it went viral and started being used in all kinds of situations.
Maybe gobsmacked was how the viewers of that TV news programme felt. You know, the mistaken
subtitle you asked me about in your question. I guess the incorrect subtitle was we can't allow
Spider-Man to become Prime Minister. Which was the wrong answer I'm afraid. In fact, the interview
he said we can't allow that man to become Prime Minister. Speaking about Boris Johnson,
but the misheard subtitle appeared as Batman. Okay, let's recap the vocabulary we've learnt
from this programme on subtitles, starting with genre. A style of film, music or book with its
own particular set of characteristics. Something which is upbeat is cheerful, hopeful and lighthearted.
The adjective jaunty means full of energy and confidence. If you gasp, you take in a short,
quick breath of air in surprise or in pain. You can use the slang expression gobsmacked when someone
is so surprised they can't speak. And finally, if you give someone a high five, you hold up your hand
above your head, clapping hands with somebody else as a greeting or to say well done. Once again,
our six minutes are up. Goodbye for now. Bye.